[Music]
okay evening members
good evening members welcome to the
cabinet meeting on 23rd of september
fire alarm procedures
if the fire alarm is activated vacate
the offices via the stairs please do not
use the lifts assembling hawley square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
please switch off your mobile phones to
silent and do not make or receive calls
whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for member of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure 20.1
item 4 councillors ghana austin everett
and yates
are there any other members requesting
to speak
apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor bay
bob bayford
does anyone have an in any interest to
declare any items of business on the
agenda this evening
minutes of the previous meeting to
approve the samian of recommendations
and decisions of the cabinet meeting
held on the 31st of august 2021
the copy is attached to the agenda pack
i propose that we approve the minutes do
i have a seconder
councillor saunders
do members agree
item four
financial management review to introduce
councillor david saunders
thank you leader purely for the
background i would confirm
that the council's financial procedure
rules
and contract standing orders are due for
being updated additionally the council
is in the process of procuring a
replacement financial management system
to replace our current system
in the light of these changes and in
order to improve the quality of
financial management across the council
a consultant was employed as a critical
friend to assess current practice and to
make recommendations for the future
the consultant's report attached to this
agenda item sets out the detail and
outlines some of the positives as well
as areas where improvements could and
should in my opinion be made
although this report may appear to
contain what
could be considered back office matters
it is important that we get our
financial management right
to this end the context of section 2
particularly in 2.2 and 2.3 of the
report contains how we as a council have
not always got it right and perhaps and
i emphasize perhaps
if we had had more stringent controls in
place in the past it could have resulted
in some of the very real expensive
mistakes being avoided
section 3
of the report lists the key findings of
the review all of which i commend to the
cabinet i particularly welcome the idea
of increased budget reporting and
approval of reserves via reports to
members through the section 151 officer
i recognise that some of these changes
will take time and i look forward to
working through the action plan with
officers and cabinet i therefore move
the cabinet notes the report
thank you
thank you councillor saunders to speak
under 20.1 councillor
ghana
thank you leader thank you councillor
saunders um i've read helen sietrum's
review of financial management
governance with interest
along with mr bullis's report
well i know
council austin
has a couple of comments and questions
to make about increasing member
involvement as suggested in the review
i'd like to ask about some of the issues
relating to our reserves that are
mentioned in the report as councillor
saunders
mentions section two highlights
uh various historic and current one-off
events that have caused major dents to
our reserves so i have two questions
um firstly how much available reserves
do we count or how much available
reserves do we currently have
available to us
and number two
what steps can or are we considering
taking to build up our available
reserves again
thank you councillor ghana and council
saunders
thank you for the question very good
question i think we knew this was coming
i've got copious notes with regards to
the minimum requirement for reserves etc
but i think i'd like to ask officers
sitting behind me for a more detailed
explanation of exactly where we are with
reserves because the figures that i've
got
may not currently be correct because
we have
made some adjustments
so
can i ask
tim willis will answer
certainly
thank you council saunders um our
reserves are about 23 million
um
they're much higher than you might think
because about we have currently about 10
million pounds of reserves
which are really technical it relates to
a specific grant for specific purposes
in relation to timing of business rates
all of that 10 million is is in right
now but it will all be out so we can
effectively um discount that
on in general i'd say our reserves have
been
steady over the last five years
steadily low but steady
sit for conduct a resilient survey every
year and
of all councils
and
what um vanit where authentic comes in
in its positioning in respect of
district councils is
we do have very low reserves absolute
reserves and reserves compared to our
net revenue expenditure in comparison to
other districts around the country
but we do relatively well on
the direction of travel because we have
managed to sustain our level of reserves
around about the same level or slightly
higher over over a number of years
despite some of these events that are
described in the report in terms of
looking forward
we've um we're just developing a budget
and medium-term financial strategy which
is going to be reported to to cabinet in
on the 21st of october and that will
contain a bit more information although
as more information becomes available
from a variety of sources but mainly
from government regarding its policy and
its funding we'll know a lot more
towards the end of the year when we come
to
agree the budget in february next year
but
our general principle is that we are
striving to replenish our reserves to
increase our reserves over the medium
term
at the moment we're not certain that
we'll be able to do that certainly next
year because we face a particular range
of budget challenges next year but in
general we have a principle that we want
to increase our reserves and that's
borne out by external audit advice and
recommendations
thank you
thank you mr willis and now you can
understand why i didn't answer that
question directly
far too many figures with me thank you
thank you um
councillor to speak under 20.1
councillor austin
thank you leader
and thank you councillor saunders uh my
question is about as as casa ghana has
highlighted um increased member
involvement i i really welcome the
many references i think i counted about
seven paragraphs in the report that
specifically recommended greater member
involvement generally
and um particularly about
a collective sent of us all working
together in a spirit of no surprises in
a spirit of of collective and individual
responsibilities for financial
management to strengthen
accountabilities
and
i was interested in the idea about
members being involved in some kind of
challenge arrangement um and i wondered
if the cabinet member for finance could
say whether he would welcome greater
member involvement and if so how as
ordinary members we might be able to
prepare ourselves for that and help with
that thank you
thank you for the question and i think
people who know me know that i have a
desire to be as transparent and open as
possible
and as far as
the challenges that we face with regards
to the budget coming up i think it's
essential that we involve as many
members as we possibly can i know the
151 officer and i have had conversations
already with regards to the regular
budget briefings that he has
carried out over the last two years and
that will continue and as we adopt this
new financial strategy i think members
will see
more involvement with key decisions
ultimately those decisions will be the
cabinet but
all of the input that we can gather from
members would be welcome
particularly in smoothing
such decisions that might be difficult
through the process thank you
thank you
i would also endorse the um necessity
for
obviously all members to produce a
balanced budget for this council so it
is essential that
you know we have cross-party consensus
and obviously involvement in that thank
you
next to speak under 20.1 councillor
everett
um thank you yeah i mean i wasn't going
to say about member involvement but um
as it's been discussed
um
i think we have to be open about this i
mean one of the problems with member
involvement is members not getting
involved rather than not having
opportunities and i think that um you
know the finance team have certainly in
terms of the budget um been given many
opportunities for members to get
involved and it disappoints me when some
members of this council don't take up
those opportunities and at the same time
i recognize that some members find the
financial detail of the council and
local government finance quite
challenging so i think we have to
recognize that we have to give as many
opportunities as possible for people to
learn about it um but obviously you can
have as many opportunities as you like
and if people don't take them up then
you know that's not going to work and in
terms of next year's budget of course
the more transparent and open the
administration is the more chance there
is that we will be able to vote for the
budget on the night and certainly
if the administration is is open and
transparent then you'll have the
cooperation of the labour group and
trying to reach what are probably going
to be some difficult decisions
um
what i really wanted to say was over and
above the fact that i welcome the
financial management review and i think
there's some interesting and positive
suggestions in there i think it's a good
document um but i'm afraid i have to
take issue with 2.3
um
and and this sort of hit list of things
that have gone wrong allegedly over the
last six years
um and it won't surprise mr willis i'm
going to talk about trans europa fairies
probably um because i have to say that
trans europa fairies went bust in early
2013
which wasn't in the last six years and
as far as i'm aware um the
the debt on the council's book of the
the loss on the council's books was
covered in
2013-14
so i don't think it sits in the scope of
the um time frame that's been suggested
and i also want to say that the
trans-europa ferries issue is not the
same as the others
it was an external event which was
outside the control of the council the
council did not cause trans-europa
ferries to go bust
what he did in fact by decision
originally of the conservative cabinet i
think in 2010
was to make a decision um to temporarily
suspend collection of their birthing
fees
so that that money um did not come into
the council but it would never have come
into the council and if the council
would continue to collect the birthing
fees in all probability trans europa
would have gone bust earlier so whilst i
accepted it's an accounting loss because
we budgeted for that income and we we
applied it to services that money was
spent in fanny on finance services
so i think it's i think it's important
to make that distinction and i don't
like the fact to be honest with you that
this list of events is all thrown into
this report which is largely about
something else
because i think it
it misleads the public and it creates
unnecessary headlines
in the media about than its financial
position we all know it's serious we all
know there's work to do
but i'm afraid that if members don't
have a full grasp of the finances the
media certainly don't and they will jump
on anything that appears
the other thing that it occurs to me to
say is that i think three of the things
that mr willis refers to are connected
to the pool
and we shouldn't lose sight of the fact
that the port is quite an unusual
undertaking for a district council and
the truth is that as a small district
council we don't have the resilience to
deal with these one-off events in the
way that a unitary authority or a bigger
council
with more finances would have so we are
peculiarly susceptible
to issues i think around the pool but
also to other financial shocks
which is why probably um the district
council model as part is passed itself
by date i think we all have doubts about
whether there should be a a district
council structure in this area in future
and that will be one way of addressing
the financial position although there
are there is a democratic accountability
problem i think with large unitary
authorities
the only other thing i wanted to say was
that in the report i noticed uh it
refers to the proposal to bring it back
in-house
um i have heard whispers of that before
but i'm not sure that the council said
anything publicly about that so perhaps
we can have an update on where we are
with that thank you
thank you and
thank you very much for the first part
of your presentation
as you well know in the past i have
asked members to attend meetings and it
is very difficult
or it's very easy to criticize after the
event if you don't bother to have any
input
on the other parts of your conversation
i think that was well received by myself
and understood that it was quite
probably coming forward and hopefully
the new arrangements will have a better
reaction and a better outcome for that
thank you
the on
[Music]
you you okay you
you're coming first tim willis first and
then chief executive on on the thorny
question of i t
thank you chad um just on the it issue i
think
the references in the consultants report
council everett
um
it's i have to apologize for that
because um when i was turning the this
into a cabinet report
and we decided to include the whole of
the consultants report because we
thought that was the most transparent so
there was
it wasn't as if anybody was
manipulating or extracting just the
favorable parts of a consultant's report
we wanted to include the whole report
and we had requested this the extraction
of that reference to ict because it
hasn't been decided yet but then it
wasn't changed and nobody wanted to
amend the consultants report other than
allowing the consultant to do it so it
was still there and it isn't something
that is our policy at the moment i'm
sure the chief exec can elaborate on
that further
just in respect of the um
references to the usage of reserves i'm
i'm
not going to get into a debate about the
the merits of having a pool
and and or not having a pool but
this report is is a financial management
review
and the point is making here is
referring to
our level of reserves
and the fact is if the instances in 2.3
had not occurred we would now have 9
million pounds more in our reserves and
i think that's the point it's making
thank you mr willis chief executive he
wanted to come in
thank you chairman yes just on the
i.t issue
and reference to coming in house i can
confirm there's no formal decision to do
that at this point but members will be
aware that that's a part of a shared
service
and is something that three local
authorities in east kent would be
involved in
but just to be absolutely upfront about
things uh there have there will be an
exploratory conversation amongst the
east kent chiefs
in uh due course it's not imminent but
in due course to have a to consider
whether that is something they want to
consider
bringing back into the three separate
organizations but there's no formal
decision on that yet
when we are in a position we of course
want to inform the appropriate staff
members and members at that point thank
you
thank you and before i bring counselor
yates in under 20.1 um
just going to cancel over it um
worryingly this is two things that we
actually agree on in the year 2021 is
that
i also believe that
the future of a
district authority is probably not the
model going forward and the combined
authority would certainly solve quite a
few of the issues which and it might
even solve some of the issues regarding
the housing
as well so that we're expected to
provide so i think that would be a
benefit and something that maybe we can
all have a have a dis and certainly
something i'm discussing with other kent
uh leaders well certainly east kent uh
leaders
um
so pass over to council yates who's
speaking under 20.1 thank you
yeah thank you leader um so yeah i fully
support this financial manager of
management review
um and i agree with councillor austin
that it would be good to see more member
involvement and to see these suggested
improvements followed through
um for example reducing the current key
decision threshold from 250 000 um
to a lower number is something i 100
agree on as i believe that is currently
too high
um and the monthly by exemption
monitoring reports i think that's a
sound financial um suggestion as well
um so my question is um
rather different but uh
it is connected um does the cabinet
agree that
financial management
is even more important these days after
10 years of what our government cuts to
local government with our budget reduced
by about 30 percent since 2010
thanks
council summers would you like to
respond on behalf of the cabinet
i would indeed i think
we we do agree that um all of the
financial um
jigsaw parts need to be put together
when we sit down and do the budget um
as the
151 officer has already indicated the
cabinet won't see the proposals
until the 21st of october and
i'm hoping that all of the known
costs etc
and anything that's coming down from
central government will be embedded in
that so that we can have a useful
discussion and uh sit back and
see exactly where we are but yes we'll
take everything into account
in our discussions when we um come to
get a balanced budget
as you well know from our
regular meetings
i'm not one to
uh not put my head above the parapet
shall we say so the answer will come
once we know all the facts thank you
thank you councillor saunders um to move
the recommendation to know the
thank you do i have a seconder
counselor
do members agree
thank you
item five
is an update on costs of grievance and
disciplinary procedures and i will
introduce this
the report is self-explanatory however
in a brief note it might be
wise to point out originally the costs
of our ongoing proceedings were reported
to cabinet on the 8th of june
members requested to see regular updates
on costs and were advised that gpc is
the appropriate committee to have
oversight of costs
gpc considered and noted an update
report on the cost on the 25th of august
but also requested that the cost be
reported to cabinet
as previously stated in june the
estimate the estimate of current future
cost is based on the current worst case
scenario
these costs have yet to be incurred but
obviously have to be identified and
estimated
those costs might change depending on
the outcome of co of current proceedings
no one is actually asked to speak under
this i don't know if anyone
no so there's no
so i'm asking um cabinet to uh note the
report
and do i have a seconder
councillor pugh
does members agree
i
agree
so that concludes the business for the
cabinet this evening and i declare the
meeting closed at 18 22